fifth harmony taking a break what led to
the group's decision and why Miley and
Liam are being super secretive about a
possible wedding plus Blue Ivy's big bid
at the wearable art gala
happy Monday team this is the daily
Denny your daily entertainment news fix
and I don't know about you but we woke
up to some big news from the girls of
fifth harmony the group has announced
they are officially taking a break to
pursue solo endeavors and to be fair the
girls Lauren norm on Edina and Ally have
been nearly a task at the hip for six
years literally together since they were
teamed up together on the x-factor and
after kamila left the all-girl group now
source close to five H tells et these
girls have been working virtually every
day non-stop for six years they needed
time on their own the group shared a
statement on Twitter that read in part
we are all very excited and grateful to
be able to take this time to learn and
grow creatively and really find our
footing as individuals now for those
thinking this is a sign of some bad
blood with the ladies don't worry
Harmonizers a source close to the group
tell CT there is no drama over this I
ate us adding Camila Kibeho leaving the
group had nothing to do with this break
they have had a number one album since
she left and this is entirely about them
taking time to be individuals and you
know maybe the signs were always there
guys
nor money joined Dancing with the Stars
March of last year and it was the first
time fans really saw the spotlight on
one member outside the group and then
two months after that lauren teamed up
with Halsey for strangers until et at
Jingle Ball at the end of the year that
all the girls were exploring their own
projects it's really cool cuz we're just
kind of branching out to creatively
discover ourselves cuz we never really
got an opportunity to do that since we
started this when we were like 6 I was
16 when I started you know Lauren and
listen from what the girls have all told
us over the past year fifth harmony is
still their priority and the the really
amazing thing is that we have such an
incredible bond with the four of us
and we're definitely like yes see you
guys all love but I do want to know what
do you guys think of fifth Harmony's
decision I feel like it was only a
matter of time before they tried to go
out and do their own things for a bit
and you know what clearly it's working
for one direction so why not then - time
will tell though and speaking of the
clock is ticking on a possible wedding
for Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth a
source tells ET the couple is more
committed to each other than ever and an
upcoming wedding could be in the stars
now after nine years off and on the
source says their timing is finally
right a ranch wedding simple and very
secretive those are the things on
Miley's wedding to-do list as for when
it'll happen our source tells us she and
Liam are not rushing down the aisle they
don't want to feel pressured only their
friends will know at the very last
minute so what's changed while we're
told Liam's parents were not sold on
Miley's outrageous behavior drug and
alcohol use but Chris Hemsworth's wife
Elsa went to bat for Miley she told the
in-laws how Miley turned her life around
and stopped partying and I mean she's
not wrong you've seen a total Miley
image overhaul and I for one am grateful
that we have retired the tongue for now
as for why both Miley and Liam are
already wearing rings on that finger
apparently it's a sign of their
commitment their friends refer to them
as promise rings and you know what Liam
and Miley are both good with that I mean
while Beyonce put the art and wearable
art at a charity art auction on Saturday
looking like a nubian queen that's right
the queen bee and mini-me Blue Ivy made
a powerful fashion statement at the
wearable art gala benefiting mom Tina's
wacko organization and bee was awarded
the Humanitarian Award now the theme
from a wacko
to Wakanda and Beyonce brought the
fierceness in a custom value knee and
Shane peacock stunner but it was jay-z
and bees adorable heir whose big bid on
a art piece stole the show 19
yes 19 blue I mean a $19,000 auction bid
from six-year-old Blue Ivy Carter I mean
just a day in the life of beyoncé and
jay-z's kids am i right and as I told
you guys last week blues favorite
pastime is shopping who knew that it
wasn't just clothes she loved art
ultimately though she was outbid by
Tyler Perry so sorry blue all right guys
that's it for today thanks for watching
if you liked what you saw give us a
thumbs up and of course share the video
we'll be back tomorrow with more daily
Denney so make sure you are subscribed
to our YouTube channel and I'll see you
guys then man I wish I was Blue Ivy